who with santa clara county forcing the
49ers out of the area and obviously now
in arizona the nfl has had
communications with both of the la
franchises about
a potential forced move in the coming
weeks and because of the pandemic and
you look at the restrictions that are
coming back into place in california and
los angeles county we are just
a news cycle away possibly from the same
dynamic you talked about earlier with
the san francisco 49ers players finding
out all via text or news alert
simultaneously they got a move that may
happen to uh
to the uh chargers and the rams
the difficult part of this is mike who
wants them
you know
where are you gonna go you almost have
to you really you almost have to pick
um an nfl franchise somewhere in the
west
you know maybe you could relocate uh to
dallas maybe you could relocate to
denver but it's hard to say
let's say oh we'll go to the university
of oregon or whatever first of all the
governor of the state of oregon is
probably not going to want
that
not going to want people to come in
secondly the nfl is going to have to go
in there to find out you know what are
the facilities like what you know and
where are you going to practice where
are you staying
all that other stuff i mean so to me
if if they have to move
i think you should focus on a
non-arizona
western site there aren't very many of
them
you've got to have an nfl stadium
because you have to have the real-time
high-speed
state-of-the-art communication pipeline
to 345 park avenue jerry jones would
take them all on if he could he'd put 30
000 people in the stands for every game
bring them on give me all of them i
think the rams definitely would end up
in dallas and i think the chargers quite
possibly would end up in las vegas if it
comes to that peter
i you look wherever it happens it's
going to be inconvenient and you're
going to have a lot of fodder next week
mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports